[Música]
es que hoy 20 de enero 2022 cuando se
cumple un año de la llegada al poder de
joe biden el presidente estadounidense
defendió su gestión a la fecha al tiempo
que dijo que cree que rusia invadiera
ucrania y generó confusión sobre cuál
será la respuesta de occidente en una
rueda de prensa de casi dos horas
vaivenes o un balance de su mandato
hasta ahora en lo relativo a la pandemia
la economía y la inflación además los
proyectos de ley pendientes sobre gasto
social y derecho al voto también las
relaciones con latinoamérica rusia china
irán y yemen aunque vaya y negó que
hubiera prometido demasiado en su
campaña electoral y opinó que ha hecho
las cosas mejor de lo esperado dadas las
circunstancias él sí reconoció que hay
mucha frustración y fatiga por la
pandemia del cob y 19 como ha sido
entonces este primer año de gobierno y
cuáles son los retos pendientes pues
saludo a nuestro primer invitado el día
rafael piñeros experto en temas de eeuu
y también profesor de relaciones
internacionales en la universidad
externado de colombia gracias rafael por
estar nuevamente con nosotros aquí en el
francia 24 bienvenidos américa por
supuesto empiezo por preguntarle el
balance general de este primer año de
gobierno de dubai a
buenos días y gracias por la invitación
considero que el primer año de yo vaya
en el poder ha sido más bien regular
como candidato él identificó al menos
cuatro importantes crisis la crisis del
coronavirus es decir un proceso de
vacunación que inicia de manera lenta la
situación climática porque los desastres
eventualmente los incendios forestales y
la pérdida de biodiversidad
amenazan varios estados de los eeuu por
supuesto la crisis económica que hace un
año planteaba una un incremento
significativo en el desempleo una
pérdida de la confianza y eventualmente
unos resultados más duros en términos de
más del crecimiento económico y al mismo
tiempo una crisis interna derivada del
blacklight mar y al mismo tiempo de la
insurrección que dos demás dos semanas
antes de su inauguración el 20 de enero
había sucedido en el capitolio de los
estados unidos a partir de esas
múltiples crisis él identificó para cada
una de ellas posibles soluciones si bien
en algunas o en casi todas hay
resultados positivos también hay
elementos que a la larga o al día de hoy
le han venido restando puntos por
ejemplo si nosotros no nos detenemos en
la crisis económica nos vamos a dar
cuenta de que los paquetes de estímulos
que se pasaron especialmente en los
primeros meses de su administración han
tenido al día de hoy un efecto muy
importante en la inflación que es más
alta que los últimos 40 años pero al
mismo tiempo ha facilitado mantener el
desempleo bajo y relativamente
controlado y que el crecimiento
económico sea positivo de lo que yo
quiero mostrar con ello es que el
balance puede que en unos elementos sea
positivo y en otros sea
significativamente regular lo que hace
que hoy la percepción desde el primer
año será más bien pobre rafael entonces
ya vimos un panorama general de las
dificultades que se encontró entonces yo
vaivén cuando asumió esta presidencia y
también lo que ha sido más o menos este
año de gobierno pero ahora hablemos de
los desaciertos y quiero que toquemos un
punto que vimos el año pasado que pues
la comunidad internacional en su amplia
mayoría varios y rechazaron la manera de
lo gráfico que fue y por supuesto habló
de la retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses y la coalición
internacional de afganistán como también
le jugó esto en su contra bajándole la
popularidad por supuesto
principalmente a joe biden
de hecho los primeros seis meses de una
administración suelen ser un periodo de
calma porque hay que mirar cómo se sitúa
esa administración y yo creo que el
punto que empieza a cambiar la situación
es la retirada y rápida express que se
hizo de afganistán en efecto para el
ciudadano promedio de los eeuu no le
importa
significativamente lo que suceda en un
país como afganistán pero empezamos a
observar que a partir de ese hecho se
empezaron a dar cuenta de que su falta
de acción para mantener controlada
también las nuevas variantes del
coronavirus a partir de ese elemento se
observó que las relaciones con el
congreso e incluso con miembros de su
partido eran particularmente defectuosos
entonces en efecto en materia de
política exterior uno podría pensar que
ese elemento de tono
empezó a observar otros hechos que a
nivel interno también estaban sucediendo
y que requerían de una acción más rápida
sin duda la guerra en afganistán era una
guerra de la cual muy difícilmente él
iba a salir victorioso un aumento de
tropas hubiera sido astrofísico para las
arcas públicas pero al mismo tiempo una
retirada planeada como lo pretendió
hacer resultó ser un fiasco porque sin
duda alguna los actores especialmente
internos del grupo talibán y algunas
otras guerrillas y grupos al margen de
la ley sabían que esa situación iba a
suceder y empezaron a tomar control de
los territorios más distantes de kabul
que los eeuu no podía controlar entonces
por un lado perdía pero por el otro
también y a partir de allí también exit
generó una nueva relación de tensión con
los aliados europeos no sólo hay que
mencionar también los elementos
importantes creo que y es que los
conflictos y la tensión con china que
venía desde la administración donald
trump no ha cambiado no se ha modificado
sino que ha buscado llevarse en los
términos distintos a los de
confrontación directa que se llevaron
bajo la administración de donald trump
hay dos temas rafael que quiero tratar
en estos minutos minuticos minutitos que
nos queda de conversación el primero es
la pandemia de kobe 19 presidente vayan
prometió
y va a hacer todo lo posible para que
todo el país estuviera vacunado y se
encontró una gran reticencia de parte de
la población que no se quiere vacunar
con el kobe 19 y no ha cumplido digamos
su promesa de campaña que va a pasar
entonces con la pandemia de kobe 19 la
promesa del presidente vayan
lastimosamente las sociedades se
comportan de una manera distinta a la
que espera el político o el experto en
materia de salud que lo viene
acompañando desde el inicio de la
pandemia al aumentar las tasas de
vacunación divine disminuyeron las tasas
de personas que tenían que recurrir un
abuso o que eventualmente podrían
fallecer en efecto eso ha sucedido en
todos los países y yo creo que hoy el
menos incentivos para que las personas
se vacunen una crítica muy fuerte que le
hacen es que en julio justo para la
celebración del día de la independencia
yo vaya mencionó que la pandemia estaba
prácticamente controlada pero observamos
que nuevas variantes como la del está o
la que hoy tenemos omicron ha
significado que la gente perciba
mensajes contradictorios por parte de la
administración central y esa situación
hace que pareciese que hay una crisis
generalizada es cierto que en los
centros médicos han aumentado el número
de pacientes que llegan es cierto que
hay una crisis actualmente o una
disminución del personal sanitario
básicamente porque muchos están
contagiados
pero también es cierto que las personas
que fallecen y que van a fallecer en los
próximos días va a ser mucho menor de lo
que sucedió en picos anteriores entonces
démonos cuenta como la sensación y la
percepción puede ser una en los
resultados objetivos pueden indicarnos
otra cuestión no quiere decir que lo
esté bien de hecho hay una crítica muy
fuerte a por qué no aumentar de una
manera más decidida el número de testeos
de pruebas pcr por otro tipo para saber
quiénes están o no contagios rafael ya
rápidamente para finalizar la migración
ese es un tema supremamente complicado
porque desde desde mediados de la década
de los 80 no hay una actualización de la
ley migratoria en los eeuu encomendará
kamala harris y darle un papel
protagónico a su vicepresidenta tal vez
no ha sido la jugada más efectiva porque
si bien realizó una gira importante
sobre centroamérica para tratarse de
incentivar la llegada de inmigrantes por
rutas ilegales vemos que esa situación
no ha cambiado él dijo que iba a tener
un trato más humanitario y que
evidentemente los migrantes necesitan
una respuesta más expedita y más humana
por parte de las autoridades
estadounidenses cuando llegaran a suelo
británico pero las imágenes también de
cómo los guardias fronterizos enfrentado
en ocasiones a migrantes provenientes de
haití y otros países no los deja muy
bien parados el problema es que con los
márgenes que tienen en este momento en
el congreso es muy difícil enfrentarse a
un proyecto de ley de reforma migratoria
cuando eventualmente no tengan los votos
suficientes y cuando el senado
especialmente partido en dos
no logré una mayoría cualificada
necesaria para pasar este tipo de
legislación